over the last 10 years a lot of research
has come out that says napping in the
middle of the workday makes us more
alert more focused and just overall more
productive employees so I'm gonna see if
it's realistic to map on-the-job deaths
aren't the most comfortable places to
sleep so this whole NAP gadget industry
has popped up selling these devices that
claim to make sleeping at your desk
practical and realistic I've ordered for
nap helpers to help me an optimize my
workday that's the phrase I learned
online first up is a device called the
rapid nap
it's a pillow blindfold and ear muff
that wraps around your face I'm gonna
set an alarm for 20 minutes
the wrapping up blocks out light which
is nice but despite having the
consistency of a pillow there's no
support for your head it's more like a
robust I mask the wrapping up doesn't
really do anything for sleeping at your
desk next I use the nap anywhere pillow
a padded disc that supports your head
and neck with the assistance of a body
strap it has a complex 11 step assembly
process that took me multiple tries to
figure out before I could get to napping
I think that this is more comfortable
Vanilla's but it's not great this
product was developed by a medical
professional but it's pretty terrible
it's basically a worse version of
airplane neck pillows which people
already like it also doesn't block out
any light or any sound I was
uncomfortable and again I didn't fall
asleep next we have the ostrich pillow
the most well known napping at your desk
device out there it's a full head
experience there's zero assembly
required which is how an apparatus
should come up top there's room for you
to put your arms so you can just plunk
face down onto your desk the ostrich
pillow is like wearing a straitjacket on
your face it's suffocating maybe my
expectations were too high but the
pillow didn't support my head very well
at all I could feel the desks through
the cushioning
but I did almost fall asleep and my arms
fell asleep so that counts
doesn't it the emergency nap kit takes a
different approach to the NAP aratus
game it doesn't stimulate a bed it is a
bit
it took me 20 strenuous minutes to
inflate the air mattress which already
killed my nap time and disrupted my
coworkers there's actually a part two to
the nap emergency kit it's basically a
sleeping bag you wear it's so warm and I
feel like a huge freak I was finally
ready to nap but I couldn't just lie
down in the middle of all these deaths I
found a copy room that looked like the
best option for napping in the office my
plastic half filled air mattress
actually created a pretty nice cushion I
mean I look and feel ridiculous it's
completely impractical but it's better
than the rest napping at your desk is
hard even with the help of our Napa red
eye if companies actually want to get
employees to nap they need to create a
culture where sleeping is accepted and
provide spaces for it otherwise they'll
be stuck with a bunch of bleary-eyed
overtired worker drone